sadness and anger in the city of charges
mourners carry the coffin of Yasin Abdel
Kareem one of 18 tunisians who drowned
last month trying to get to Italy
what happened to the others remains
unknown but relatives of the missing are
angered by reports that Tunisian
authorities buried some of the victims
in unmarked graves in a cemetery for
foreign migrants full bodies have since
been exhumed foreign
days of protests culminated in a general
strike on Tuesday more than 4 000 people
took to the streets demanding answers
from authorities
the first demand is to open an
investigation into all aspects of the
incident from the sinking of the boat to
the process of searching for the bodies
more than 22 000 migrants have been
intercepted off tunisia's Coast since
the start of this year it's a popular
but dangerous route for Africa migrants
trying to cross the Mediterranean to
reach the EU
food and fuel shortages in Tunisia have
led others to join too
president Kaya Saeed has called for an
investigation into what happened he
wants the people Smugglers responsible
to be found and prosecuted
but until economic conditions improve in
Tunisia people will continue to risk
their lives in search of a better life
in Europe Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera